Hello, this is Dr. Cabin-Cutters and welcome to module five call this program that you write, but really
We're going to talk about other technologies a little bit as well. We have
Well actually have some other videos not just on the right, but on other technologies on this site soon as well
So if you can't find it make sure you come back and we'll get those up as soon as possible
But
Always the practice of medicine is trying to use more and more technology as technology becomes available
We want to use it, but when you search cancer technologies out there
You're going to hear about different robotic surgeries. You're going to hear about bone marrow transplant targeted therapy immunotherapy
You know, these are all medical technologies and they can be very good
And they can be very hard on your body as well
That's what we're talking about. It's an alternative perspective. We're not talking about using these kind of things on this slide
We're talking about using specific therapies
So I speak about a lot of those different therapies in my book on our website. We speak about a lot of those different therapies
Hyperthermia is a great therapy to help stimulate
Bioflow and liver detoxification can help decrease pain
It can help specifically kill cancers that are near the surface like certain breast cancers and even skin cancer
So hyperthermia is raising the temperature of the tissue to a point where it's safe for healthy normal cells, but for cancer cells that are
You could say less more fragile
High increasing the temperature of that cancer cell can literally cause cell lysis
That's a type of pathological death that we want to take place in a cancer cell
So hyperthermia is one of those technologies
Pemf pulsed electromagnetic field therapy is another therapy. That isn't really a cancer killing therapy
But it could help with other side effects from cancer therapies or the cancer itself with pain or
Just lack of energy what a Pemf unit does is adds a charge of electricity to your body in a pulsed fashion
Like I'm talking like this because it's giving you this boom boom boom electrical charge
Which all your cell membranes have an electrical charge
So by adding this post electromagnetic field
Charged to your cells. It can really help boost
fatigue levels energy levels can strengthen
healthy cells
Can strengthen your immune system and indirectly then be good to help kill cancer cells
But I wouldn't say it's a cancer killing therapy
But if you have access to a Pemf cancer patients do really well
It adds to your whole protocol in body health. So Pemf therapy is a great addition
Plus it's we like to use it with patients that may have metastasis. It's the bone
um
And have pain because of that because probably the number one use of Pemf worldwide is really for pain
For people with chronic pain or a de-injury or back injury Pemf really shines for that
So certainly with metastasis or pain from your cancer for any reason
Pemf can be very beneficial
Of course if you've watched any of my information
The rife machine is really big in my book. That's how I got started
Taking care of cancer patients is because of this love for this rife machine that God put in my heart
Way back in the 1980s when I was in school
Well, that seems like a long time ago now
I'm an old man
but the rife machine was
It's just a great tool. That's how I started taking care of patients with the cancer diagnosis
God really instilled in my heart this love of this rife machine
I just had this just desire you know says in the book of Hosea that he will put his desires in your heart
He will give you the desires of your heart and I read that as God will put his desires in your heart
And he certainly put that desire about rife technology in my heart
First time I saw anything about Royal Raymond rife in his work. I was intrigued and
Before I purchased my first machine. I had investigated the types of rife machines that were out there in the 90s
Because that's what I was looking at them
I had
said I had called the company sent had them sent some
Information this is before really the internet and they I had some a pamphlet of the rife machine that I was going to buy taped up
To my desk on the wall in front of my desk at my clinic
And it wasn't until the late 90s when a patient came in and said she had breast cancer in both breasts
And they gave her three months to live if she didn't do chemo
She wasn't gonna do chemo
That was my aha moment my Holy Spirit moment to buy a rife machine
purchased a rife machine she came in daily and used it. That's when we did it in our office
And she lived another 13 years. So
I don't take credit for that. I don't even give them the rife machine credit for that. Obviously God is our healer
He's the one who kept that person alive
And
lived you know years beyond what was expected
But I do give some credit to work on leads us and the rife machine is what he led me to that is a big part of my purpose
Is to help people with frequency. So what is the rife machine the rife machine
is
Using technology to our benefit. It is a hidden gem
It was really
Invented initially by royal rabid rife heads the name of it
But there's a lot of different rife quote-un-me quote machines out there that I wouldn't call rife machines
Because to me if it's truly a rife machine
It has to use light frequency
So if you're holding on to some little
Panels or you're putting little stickers on your body or you're listening to an audio through headphones or something
It is frequency therapy and it is frequency healing and I'm not discounting the benefits to that
But if you really want to help kill cancer cells
I think my opinion you need to use light frequencies
So royal rabid rife is the inventor. He was a microscope manufacturer and you could read all about him on our website
We'll put some links to different things about him on this um site as well
But he is the one who this was in the burgeoning of
Quantum physics and quantum mechanics with the understanding went beyond
Uh
Newtonian physics to an understanding that everything down to its smallest particle is simply energy that's vibrating at a specific frequency
And a fairly unique frequency to that thing
So that's what makes that thing up and that's really
In the understanding of quantum physics is what royal rabid rife came up with if if we could hit cancer frequency
Cancer cells at their own frequency could we cause them to implode
Could we cause lysis
Um a pathological death of that cancer cell that was his philosophy
Um, he didn't have any way to prove that
Um, though he could do it in a petri dish
Well, not everything works in the body the way it works in a petri dish
But he did have success with patients and then the 1950s rolled around and that's when the
AMA was coming and confiscating any practitioner that was not using pharmacology
That's when all the cancer clinics in Mexico were birthed because these people were run out of the country
Hoxy and Gerson well rife just gave up the ghost because they confiscated his machines
And he ended up dying in alcoholic very sad situation
But um his technology wasn't totally lost the government used it during the Cold War to try to actually
To try to use it to create germ
So if we filed the frequency for anthrax could we
Hit somebody run it on a rife machine hit somebody with the frequency of anthrax and cause anthrax
Well, the problem with that is it doesn't cause disease if that person had anthrax
It would help their body kill anthrax
It doesn't cause anthrax so it was scraped into the freedom of information act
All this money spent on mapping out the quantum physics frequency for
Thousands of diseases was made available to practitioners like me
So and then you add that to the decades of work of different practitioners
Trying to figure out the frequencies of different cancers and what will work best for different cancers
We have come up with a lot of different frequencies for a most every cancer there is and
That's the use of rife today using these frequencies to our advantage
Yes, his work was suppressed knowledge
And it really went into the dark ages in the 50s in the 60s
But when the 70s rolled around and people started reading about some of his stuff
practitioners like me and a lot of people smarter than me started to create some different machines that had an advantage
And could help people with cancer the first machine I bought in the 90s was probably
About a 50th time as powerful as the machines we use today
So as this knowledge advances and as technology advances
We're able to create better machines that are going to have a better effect on the body
So we use this machine right here. It's true right in the office
We also use a GP 4000
But this is the one that we use that we sent home with patients
And this is the one that I really sell because of a couple factors
So what I analyze a type of rife machine and what I want to use for myself or my patients
And look at a few different factors
Number one, isn't powerful enough to produce energy out of that bulb that is going to penetrate my body
To affect the cancer that's deep in my body
So there's a lot of rife machines on the market or machines that call themselves rife machines that
Do not do that
So they might have some effect on superficial things
But they're not powerful enough to penetrate your body
So well to me, what good is that?
Secondly, does it use light frequency? I already talked about that
If you're not using light frequency for cancer, I think you're missing the boat completely
So it does have to have a Tesla tube, a gas-vogue tube that do the light frequency
To carry that wave through your body
And then thirdly, is it programmable?
So I mean if there's just some programmed
Things with the machine, they may be good, they may be bad
But they're not necessarily going to be specific to me
So if it's not programmable for me, I don't want to use it
Because I want to get very specific to the frequencies that I want to run
So the GB 4000 and the true rife are really the two that are left with that
And then lastly, is it really easy to use and is it going to last a long time
So to me, that's where the true rife shines
I have no investment in this company
And I probably shouldn't even mention their name on here
But you can go to rife and buy one of their machines
I have no problem with that, I think you should
I think everybody should have one
My kids have one that don't have cancer
So my grandkids can use it if they come down with a cold or anything like that
These, this is where the rife machine shines
It shines on killing biotoxins
It shines on helping your body kill cancer cells
Kill it killing living things
That's where the rife shines as a tool
You want to use any tool correctly
You don't use a hammer to pound in a screw
You don't use a screwdriver to pound in a nail
So you use tools as they're created
So this is where the rife shines
We put on there there's over 2500 different programs
And then we get specific for that person's type of cancer
And I've written, doing this for 20-some years
I've written a program for just about every possible cancer there is
My cancer was extremely rare
There was zero known frequencies for my cancer
And I actually struggled and if you read on our website
About my personal experience
I really didn't think I was gonna make it three years ago
I was pretty positive if I wasn't
And there was some dark days there
But it wasn't until I figured out the frequency that worked for me
That it really changed the corner
It turned the corner for me
And why I'm speaking to you today
So I give rife a lot of credit
I'm very thankful for what this man did in his work
I'm thankful for how God used him even though he wasn't a believer
God still uses things to his and for his glory
That's my belief
So using the right frequencies is key
The Tourette comes with about 2500 other programs that I said
And then we specifically create a program for this specific cancer
And that person
And you can purchase one of our programs
It would be specific to a cheek swab test
But it will be specific to your type of cancer
And that can be extremely beneficial
So it's all in the program
It's all in the power of the machine
It's in the light frequency
It's in the ease of use of the machine
Of course, I'm really big pushing the rife machine
But you know, I don't need to make anything off it
Go buy it from true rife
I don't make anything for you doing that
So understand, I'm not trying to be biased
But my opinion is biased just because of what I've experienced
And the way God has used me
And how he's led me in my desires
I honestly don't think I'd be standing here talking you today
If it wasn't for the rife machine
So I am very biased about it
But it is
It has been a blessing in my life
And my family's life as well
And a lot of my patients
This is the machine
This is the bulb that we use
We use actually a crystallized bulb
Which I think helps separate the light
And give you even a better benefit
As the cancer tries to morph
And try to take off every way possibly a can
So we use the F-122 with all our patients
And they sleep with this crystal hammer bulb
That's what it's called
It's encased in plastic
So if you drop it on a bed and you can't break the thing
But you snuggle with it all night long
I snuggle with my bulb all night long
Or it lays right next to me
And I use it every single night
So it is a great tool
So consider different technology as it comes up
But be wise, don't just talk to one
The sales person
I've tested just about every rife on the market
And this is what I use
The others
Some other good ones too
And I'm not knocking any other products out there
But I just want to use the best thing
For me and for my patients
I mean, I feel like that's my responsibility
So I'm not going to recommend something
And I don't like what I don't think works
But if new technology comes out
I guess I'd remake this video
So I hope this is a blessing
Oh, I don't sound salesy to you
I just want what's best for you
And I want you to do the best thing
And ultimately I want you to be praying
About every decision you make
Certainly don't go by a rife
But she goes, I said it
Be prayed about it
Be asking for that fruit of the spirit
Especially that peace
And that self-control
That you need
Is you're walking
By his guidance
So that you know that you know
That you know you're doing the right thing
All right, I'll be praying for you
And I come at your prayers
For me and our clinic
Until next module
Bye bye